hey what is up guys I'm Kay PhD here and
this is the HTC one it's a pretty
awesome phone if you guys haven't
already seen the reviews I'll include my
link to my review as the first link
below the like button on this video but
on the back of this phone there's a
pretty interesting badge
it says Beats Audio it's actually become
one of the selling points of this phone
it's actually one of the most important
things about this phone at least the
speakers themselves are so without any
further ado this is Beats Audio
explained so to be honest Beats Audio
itself isn't actually the most
technically difficult thing to explain
in the world or the most difficult thing
to understand but there is so much
misinformation already out there about
Beats Audio particularly because of word
of mouth and Best Buy stores which I'll
be talking about in a second that it
kind of needs to be explained now a lot
of people already know about beats by
dre headphones those are a pretty much
separate entity but Beats has partnered
with HTC and HP to create devices like
HP laptops and HTC phones that have
Beats Audio built into them what exactly
does that mean well besides all the
marketing BS about how it's supposed to
be the exact representation of what the
artist wants you to hear in terms of
sound quality this is the most technical
video that we could find that you can
find anywhere on the internet of what
exactly Beats Audio is in a smartphone
or a laptop
let's review HD re-engineered the
headphone jack with no metal parts to
reduce ground noise the discreet
headphone amp improves stereo separation
and is more powerful than mp3 players
and other notebook computers the
dedicated audio island isolates the
audio components on the circuit board
minimizing digital interference pressing
function beyond an HP notebook with
Beats Audio will deliver music to your
ears via the headphones or speakers
exclusive to HP notebooks these machines
have been redesigned from the outside in
to deliver the ultimate notebook audio
experience with Beats Audio so the first
ones on our list are overall nice
touches they're actually pretty decent
things to have when you're talking about
audio especially a dedicated amp to
drive higher powered headphone
and for better stereo separation etc
that's pretty decent but it's really all
about that last point when you consider
Beats Audio and difference it makes
versus other devices that don't have
Beats Audio it's all about the Beats
Audio profile which is basically an
equalizer to understand Beats Audio you
have to understand what an equalizer is
so an equalizer basically human hearing
can already hear between about 20 Hertz
and 20,000 Hertz those are the
frequencies of vibrations that we can
pick up with our ears 20 Hertz being the
lowest of the low basses and 20,000
Hertz being the highest of the highs and
equalizer when you apply it to any sort
of form of audio can sort of enhance
certain portions of that audio to make
it stand out more from the others so if
I boost the audio at 15,000 Hertz you're
going to hear that portions stand out a
lot more than the other notes that
aren't in that frequency so devices with
Beats Audio built-in actually have two
audio profiles or two equalizers built
in one with Beats Audio on and one with
Beats Audio off the one with Beats Audio
on has a very exaggerated tones on
basically the low and the high end it
exaggerated s' the more interesting base
and high sections and kind of ignores
the Blessed interesting mids and the
beats audio off profile is actually a
bit of the opposite it's not completely
flat it's actually sort of under
exaggerating those interesting profiles
so it's under exaggerating the base and
under exaggerating the highs and leaving
the not so interesting mids to stand out
so when you turn Beats Audio on you
exaggerate the bass and the highs and we
turn Beats Audio off you under
exaggerate the bass in the highs which
creates a pretty big difference between
on and off so when you flick that Beats
Audio on switch on your device that
happen to have Beats Audio built in you
hear a pretty big difference and sound
and this is often what tricks people
into believing that things with Beats
Audio built in are significantly better
than what doesn't have Beats Audio
imagine this imagine you're at a Best
Buy and there are two laptops sitting
next to each other one silver one
without Beats Audio and one black one
with Beats Audio built in and comes with
a pair of beats by dre headphones and
costs five hundred dollars
the person who wants to say the laptop
is going to bring you to the one with
Beats Audio and is going to tell you hey
listen to this track with Beats Audio
turned off we're going to listen to it
it's going to sound a little bit dull
because of that weekend profile and then
he's going to turn Beats Audio on and
you're going to get that strengthened
profile and you're going to be blown
away because that laptop would Beats
Audio turned on sounds great you didn't
even have to touch the laptop in the
silver section you're already convinced
it's going to sound bad because it
doesn't have Beats Audio that's how they
get you that's how they sell you on
buying a laptop that does have Beats
Audio built in you didn't even have to
listen to the one that sounds just fine
over there because you're convinced it
sounds weak like the weak section
profile in the Beats Audio laptop so
yeah when it comes down to it Beats
Audio is less about the physical
differences inside of the phone less
about that amplifier and more about that
equalizer and most people don't realize
it but there are a lot of equalizers in
between the studio making a sound and
your actual ears your headphones for
example have their own equalizer very
few pairs of headphones are perfectly
flat and accurate most of them are going
to exaggerate some sounds here or there
and that's where you get another form of
an equalizer these by dre headphones
themselves have it slightly uneven
frequency response if you look at the
frequency response chart for a pair of
beats by dre headphones you'll see that
they respond much more powerfully to
lower basses and higher highs and they
don't really emphasize the mids as much
so we combine you know very very bass
heavy headphones with very very bass
heavy amplifier you're going to get a
really bass heavy sound and that's
what's going to impress people and make
them think that things with Beats Audio
sound great
I actually was listening to my 80 hm 50s
with the Beats Audio turned off on the
HTC One and it sounded pretty good but
again that's what the headphone jack
built-in I think the speakers on the
front sound phenomenal when you have
Beats Audio turned on or off it's just
about the clarity and the volume that
you get that changes but it definitely
depends on the device you're looking at
definitely be wary of people trying to
sell you stuff because it has Beats
Audio just have a listen to other stuff
around you first and decide it makes
enough of a difference for you so the
overall message of this video is don't
get tricked into buying something just
because it has Beats Audio built in
everyone's got an EQ figure out
yours either way that's been it thanks
for watching this video I'll leave a
video response right below of one of my
previous videos where I compare a pair
of beats by dre headphones that cost
hundreds of dollars more than a pair of
Audio Technica headphones and the
results may be really impressive to you
so that'll be linked both like button or
as a video response or whatever I happen
to do below but either way like I said
thank you for watching and I'll talk to
you guys in the next video peace
you